[Music]
there was no bomb on board the ryanair
flight that was diverted to minsk
the sniffer dogs found nothing but there
was
a journalist roman protosavic and he
knew
immediately why the aircraft had been
forced to land in belarus
when they announced that the plane is
going to be landed in minsk he jumped
from his seat
he went into a little panic he said what
is going on i can't land in minsk
i can't land over there you know i'm
going to get the death penalty
i'm going to be killed this was the last
photo taken of protosavich
before he boarded the flight in athens
nothing was heard of him
for 24 hours and then this video
was released from his prison
yesterday i was detained by belarusian
police at the airport
now i'm in minsk police station one i
can say that i don't have any health
problems with my heart
or any other organs i'm being treated
with respect
and according to the law right now i
continue to cooperate with police
and confess to organizing mass protests
in minsk
when flight 4978 finally landed in
lithuania late on sunday evening
five of the original passengers were
missing roman protese
his girlfriend and three others it's
thought
they were bella russian kgb officers i'm
sure that he's been tortured
because he knows a lot of information he
was a
leader of one famous uh telegram channel
about
civil society about the situation in
belarus and he is considered to be
like private enemy of lukashenka
so we're really afraid not only for his
freedom but
for his life international outrage has
come
thick and fast with the uk first to
announce punishment
we want to hold the perpetrators to
account we want to send a deterrent
message
to others who might uh conceivably
consider taking such
outlandish behavior we want to uphold
the international order and i think it's
very important we've not seen
anything quite as outlandish as
deceitful as dangerous as this
for at least 30 40 maybe 50 years
and in brussels eu leaders agreed to
take similar measures banning flights
and look at more economic sanctions
against belarus
with this outrageous behavior and
lukashenko and his regime have to
understand
that this will have severe consequences
roman pratasevich has to be released
immediately and we will put pressure on
the regime
as long as uh it finally respects
the freedom of media and the freedom of
press and the freedom of opinion
lithuania has told its citizens to leave
belarus for their own safety
speculation about russian involvement
hasn't been confirmed
but presidents putin and lukashenko are
reportedly due to meet
later this week the belarusian leader
has few allies now aleister bunkel sky
news